vous a choisi pour la vo pour les
oreilles décollées
je savais que ces questions arriverait
mon fils de 9 ans adore cette histoire
et roald dahl je connais voilà ce que
j'ai fait des voix il ya très longtemps
de petites histoires de roald dahl
c'est très poétique c'est très émouvant
ça va bien à spielberg moi enfant j'ai
été émerveillé par iti ben williams on
retrouve un peu cette ambiance là cette
petite fille qui vit dans un orphelinat
qui a perdu ses parents le monde du rêve
la beauté du personnage du bon gros
géant je trouve que c'est une très belle
histoire est que le film est très réussi
et très chouette c'est que le personnage
c'est un personnage âgé qui est aussi
vieux que le monde et qui est à la fois
un personnage très enfantin et très sage
et très joueurs enfin il a une sagesse
d'un grand-père et le côté ludique des
enfants tu le crois que parce que je
suis un géant je suis un cover d'hommes
khanabad un personnage profond très
émouvant très humain il véhicule
toute la beauté de l'humanité a joué
c'était jubilatoire
berdos mach mia base bay josh gorges et
le garçon boucher pour faire une synchro
ce film il ya une histoire de rythme en
fait qui est très importante
au delà de la voix après c'est une
histoire de jeu et de spontanéité
appelle moi le bon gros géant la
difficulté c'est pas tellement de le
mettre en bouche c'est que les mots
soient bien claires qu'on les entende
bien qu'on le comprenne bien qu'on
comprenne bien que c'est un mot
alambiqué retravailler
donc il faut le prononcer un peu plus
précisément il m'attrape rem enfermerait
dans une cage tout ça pour que les gens
regardent et à dimanche stratus lmj port
dame et aussi les crocodiles et les
giraud graf
il mélange les mots quoi il fait des
mots il invente des mots les et pouvant
songe par exemple c'est très joli veut
dire les cauchemars et pouvant songe
j'attrape les rêves
celui-ci en direct ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on double bobine par bobine et en
revient toujours aux premières bobines
parce que la voix évolue un peu on
s'attache aux personnages ma voix se
patine et s'adapte au fil du doublage il
y à du rire des moments de détente en
dos alors retient des poumons croise des
bouts de doigts pervenches
mais c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu le
personnage dit tiens c'est en année ne
saurait